we'd be going in short-handed you know
look he's still got the stone so that's
gonna use them to bring everyone back
just like that yeah just like that
even if there's a small chance that we
can undo this I mean we owe it to
everyone who's not in this room to try
if we do this how do we know it's gonna
end any differently than it did before
because before you didn't have me hey
new girl everybody in this room is about
that superhero life and if you don't
mind my asking where the hell have you
been all this time there are a lot of
other planets in the universe and
unfortunately they didn't have you guys
[Music]
I like this one
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
thanks to Good Morning America we
finally have that scene that everybody
has been talking about the scene that
was shown at the Disney shareholders
meeting and the scene that was recently
shown at CinemaCon this scene plays out
to the tee just as it was described but
now we have the visual for it now we
have some major confirmations it starts
off with Black Widow saying that Thanos
use the stones again so this confirms
that the Infinity Gauntlet and the
stones are still working at least
partially well enough that the Avengers
could pick up on the energy surge when
Thanos used it some of the Avengers are
a little hesitant at first saying that
they'd be going in short-handed and that
Diana still has the Infinity stones but
Captain Marvel thinks that she can
defeat Thanos so she says let's just go
get him and then use the stones to bring
everybody back and then Captain America
agrees so huge confirmation right here
the avengers says initial plan is to go
fight Thanos defeat him and use the
Infinity Gauntlet to bring everybody
back so most likely in the first 15 to
20 minutes of the movie The Avengers
will go to Titan 2 and fight Thanos
right now this is the only thing that
the Avengers know to do this is their
only option and only hope for bringing
everybody back black widow says we at
least have to try they owe it to
everybody who's not in this room to try
and just as described Bruce Banner steps
in and says how do we know it's going to
end any differently this time they
fought Thanos before and then Captain
Marvel steps in and says because before
you didn't have me you have to remember
this is way after the events of Captain
Marvel Carol Danvers has well developed
her powers by now and is most likely way
stronger than she was in Captain Marvel
so she thinks that her strength alone is
more than enough to defeat Thanos and
the arrest of the Avengers are kind of
taken back about how confident Carol
Danvers is because they just tried to
defeat Thanos with everything they had
and lost so Rhodey steps in and says hey
new girl if you're so strong where the
heck have you been all this time we're
all about that superhero life we were
all trying to defend the planet where
were you and of course she says there
are a lot of planets in the universe
that unfortunately didn't have you guys
and as you can see judging by the look
on Rody's face and captain
America's face they understand this and
that makes sense to them and then Thor
gets up and we see the scene that we've
seen before in previous trailers so that
is the footage that everybody has been
talking about since they showed it at
the Disney shareholders meeting and at
CinemaCon last weekend it's nice to
finally see it so let me know what you
think about this new footage in the
comments down below it's confirmed that
the Avengers do figure out where Thanos
says and do go fight him in the very
beginning of the movie so let me know
what you all think is going to happen
and just a reminder about my giveaway
I'm giving away a life-size Infinity
Gauntlet and a painting of Thanos by
Globe I though you can check out his art
in the link in my description all you
have to do to enter the giveaway is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]